physical physical
yeah Let's Get Physical now if you spent
any time on the Peloton bike you're
probably a fan of robbing our Zone yeah
she's the interactive home workout
company's head instructor and vice
president of Fitness programming our
Zone regularly gets thousands of people
tuning into her classes she is also an
accomplished Runner completing 27
marathons and several Ultra Miracles
which I didn't even know existed and she
also is an author of three books Shut up
and run strong mama and strong baby
which comes out in February she's here
for the exclusive unveiling cover
fitness initiative called the three for
31 challenge which she wants us all to
join which we will right Gail yeah I
don't know I want some more info okay I
got you I got you he wants the details
for more info Tony so Robin joins us
thank you for joining us um so tell us
about this December fitness challenge
it's straightforward from December 1st
to December 31st during the busiest
month of the year we reclaim our
self-care and our movement back okay how
do you do it 30 minutes a day for 31
days from December 1st to December 31st
that's it it's simple 30 minutes of
movement a day it's achievable for all
of us what type of movement though Robin
any kind of movement walk jog run do a
Peloton class with me you can dance you
can shimmy yo this this challenge was
created 10 years ago before I wrote my
first book and I needed it myself in the
busiest time of year and sometimes a
very heavy time of year yes we need
honestly movement to work through
emotions to reclaim our energy yeah you
have to do it 30 consecutive minutes 30
uh no you can break it up really that's
the beauty of it and there are days for
example this morning I did a 20 minute
run but I didn't finish my 30 minutes so
I'm gonna get back on the Peloton tread
later to finish my run and that's the
beauty of it it's like 10 minutes in the
morning 10 minutes in the afternoon 10
minutes in the evening boom you have
your 30. I get the need I get the
benefits but what do you say to people
they're like December is a month where I
plan to do the best healthy things
little hibernation is less healthy
things yes listen we have to give
ourselves Grace but later often means
never oh yeah so true okay make a choice
that you know I really want to
participate in things like with Peloton
where we're adding years to your life
and Life to your years think about the
vibrancy that you can gather at com at
our upcoming family gatherings with If
energy is currency how are we going to
spend it and I think that we have to
think about the person who's going to be
crossing the Finish Line in 2024 and who
they're going to be and I really do It
For My Future Self
it's so good Robin but I love your
backstory because listen your running
started for you out of trauma you you've
written and you've talked about being at
a bar with some friends a stranger comes
in holds everybody hostage even holds a
gun to your head and you say and you're
talking to him you say when you hold a
when a gun is held to your head you
start thinking about things how did you
go through that experience and then end
up running I mean a pair of running
shoes saved my life I was not an athlete
growing up I I'm a proud Latina but my
parents did not teach me you know
Athletics as a kid and I used running
shoes as a way to literally move and
heal I say that you were a little
medicine yes so I practice I practice
law as a corporate litigator for almost
eight years in New York City and I was
running throughout that and I guess I
ran out of a law career into Palatine
and it changed your life it did it
really changed my life and now you have
a favorite daughter and I love the
strong baby strong mama I mean and how
did your life change after having a baby
because you're still running that's a
good question yes and I think the most
significant most meaningful Marathon for
me was was the last one I did when
Athena was there cheering at Mile 23 at
nine months old and a little sweatshirt
saying Go Mama I need to be an example
for her I need to model self-care for
her self-care is not selfish and when we
can't do 27 marathons listen we start
with one step okay especially when I was
postpartum you know physically repairing
myself I my Mantra was forward is a pace
there were some days that it was like
I'm just going to take the next step and
the next step so for folks who are in
the beginning of their our Wellness
Journey feeling overwhelmed or even
Paralyzed by the fear of starting
something new start with one one
intentional choice that is going to make
today better and I love that you say
don't wait till January do it now do it
now do it now whatever comes never
people tune in to you you get them going
gave us a mantra but he's a beast what
gets you going do you have any songs
that you can recommend for people oh my
gosh there are so many listeners I have
Bad Bunny on repeat right now okay
listen my playlist right now is like a
little Taylor Swift of course we got
Mariah Carey but it's that it's been bad
bunny yeah but Athena knows how to how
to drop it like
so yeah it was funny when we were
watching the bikes but Tony goes but
they're really going somewhere I go but
you you're going somewhere on the
Peloton too yes well it's everywhere
it's a stationary bike but I know but
you were going somewhere well you are
physically going I mean in the sense
that you're transforming yourself right
yeah it's an immersive experience
connected with music and Community it's
absolutely visceral
um obviously I'm biased but I I really
see lives change every day we are not
only adding years to people's lives but
lives life to their years that's awesome
but you do get on and get off at the
very same point that's all that's all
I'm saying Robert arso thank you very
much I appreciate being here